you wrote that the queen got to watch
all of megan and harry sit down with
oprah she saw it all yes what did she
think of it i think she was appalled
shocked heartbroken all those words
because here i mean look she's going to
celebrate her sapphire jubilee your 70th
year on the throne next year nobody else
has come close to the queen victoria 63
years 70 years for queen elizabeth she
just had counted on everything being
rather stable i think in the wake of her
husband's death and that has not
happened she actually seemed very warm
and receptive to megan and harry
stepping away publicly publicly yes but
privately well not really even publicly
i mean the queen did strip him of a
number of patronages the thing that
really hurt him the most was her taking
away his military ceremonial military
titles and there have been a number of
times when there was an opportunity for
charles and william and harry to come
together i mean harry did go back for uh
prince philip's funeral yes and you
remember them walking after the funeral
service which by the way is very
touching because the queen is there
alone in the pew looking like a small
sad figure but as they walked as they
left the uh the service and and walked
up the hill harry and william were
chatting amiably kate middleton got out
of the way and let them talk a meeting
was set up with charles didn't go
anywhere harry returned to london to
unveil the statue of their mother in
kensington gardens that time they didn't
even really put on much of a show there
were a couple of moments and they looked
like they were smiling at each other but
they actually physically kept the
distance yeah they did so harry is now
saying that he and megan and archie
and lily are definitely going to the
platinum jubilee celebrations so we'll
just have to wait and see if that might
something might happen then there was a
lot made of um the fact when megan and
harry did the interview i think it was
their documentary on africa and the
journalists asked megan how she was
thank you for asking because not many
people have asked if i'm okay
but it's um
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes and then in
the oprah interview she flat out said
she sought help and they denied her why
do you think especially when there had
been so much talk about mental right
they even had a foundation right for it
right that she wasn't giving out but i
also have to say i don't think she
needed to
they don't didn't really need to give it
to her i mean she'd already had some
therapy and so had so had it harry she
managed
during after one of their more you know
harry has revealed that after a
particularly bitter argument between
megan and and harry uh you know she
convinced him to get to go to the
theater go to therapy so that does i
find that all perplexing i guess that
you know if she expected the palace to
reach out to her to lend a helping hand
that ain't gonna happen it didn't happen
for uh diana it certainly wouldn't
happen for for megan or for harry for
that i guess in her mind she was saying
but i came to like i didn't have the
resources to do it outside because they
had to give up my driver's license my
credit card right so i came to you and
said i need this help right and it was
met with
not stonewalled yeah that's what they do